the US accounts for a third of the
world's confirmed coronavirus cases and
President Donald Trump held up swabs
claiming no nation has tested more
people he says more than four million
people have already been screened and
that's now expanding to millions more is
it does it remind you of something
remind you of this right once a swab
wants a q-tip it's actually different
it's very sophisticated actually but
it's a little bit like so this is the
swamp and we've ordered a lot of them
they have a lot of them some of them
some of the states they were shipped to
States and the states don't know where
they are at Sunday's briefing the White
House showed favorable comments from
Democratic New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo in what could be seen as an
attempt to heal a growing political rift
of a Trump's determination to get people
back to work in New York where cases are
falling but remain dangerously high
Governor Cuomo says this is no time to
slow precautions or reopen too quickly
it's no time to get cocky and it's no
time to get arrogant right we still have
a lot long way to go and a lot of work
to do and this virus has been ahead of
us every step of the way we have been
playing catch-up from day one in this
situation in other parts of the nation
though small groups of protesters egged
on by the president continue to call for
an easing of restrictions the desire to
kick-start the economy is growing but
problems persist Republican governors
who rarely have critical words for their
president so they're still facing major
hurdles I could probably double maybe
even triple testing in Ohio virtually
overnight if the FDA would prioritize
companies that are putting a slightly
different formula together for the
extraction reagent kit and that's it's
if the FDA would do that we have a
shortage worldwide shortage of some of
the materials that go into this so
really need help
money from the payment
detection program designed to keep
businesses afloat has now run out even
as more than 20 million people are out
of work it's now thought US lawmakers
could meet as soon as Wednesday to
consider expanding the program but
that's already running into political
arguments despite the president's
optimism that the US will be back and
greater than ever
logistical issues political infighting
and a shortage of essential equipment
persist at this point the daily briefing
is given by President Donald Trump have
become somewhat repetitive and
increasingly political he's blamed
state's governor's for a shortage in
testing talked about the thousands of
ventilators being made and weighed in
urging certain states to be liberated
the death toll here is now by far the
highest in the world and for many this
crisis is far from over
and a Gallacher al Jazeera Miami Florida